yep joy Behar's got a much more normal
personal life than you do
Chris Ana's a Long Island medium shows
he joins us tonight so Chris that's the
resistance right I know Joyce she's got
a very nice life trust me yeah I know
where to so but I would say this that's
kind of the face of the resistance now
for the last year we've been hearing
Trump is degrading the country and I say
I kind of get what you're saying but at
the same time the left is degraded
itself to the point that Russian
collusion has somehow morphed into a
conversation about hookers and sex lives
and all this stuff that I can't describe
on TV but joy Behar's happy too I mean
are you proud of that is that kind of
where you want the conversation could be
do you think it's a valid focus of an
investigation talker you know look this
is fun to talk about but it's not
actually 18 I I don't I don't know I
think people love the salacious details
right but I don't care what the
president does in his personal life even
if any of that stuff is true I care that
the Russians may have compromised on him
that's a problem for the American people
I share about how he paid for it just
like we cared about how Eliot Spitzer
paid for it I think that's what's going
on with you know what I did not care how
valiant Spitzer paid for it and the US
government shafted Eliot Spitzer using
laws from the war on terror and the
Patriot Act
I despise Eliot Spitzer but what they
did to him was horrible I said at the
time and I'll say it again it was a
total abuse of power just like this
right you may not care about the details
of trumps personal life but how do you
feel about Ryder Moeller dispatching FBI
agents to break into his lawyer's office
to take materials on stormy Daniels and
the Access Hollywood tape I mean how how
can you I don't I do not think it was
just about that I think it might have
had something to do with Michael Cohen's
trip to Prague which he denied
vehemently which was also part of the
dossier which we are now hearing is
something that actually happened in 2016
so I think the Special Counsel is
investigating and following the evidence
where it goes and remember it was a
Republican United let her done who was
appointed by Donald Trump whatever I
know well here I you know I the last
thing I care about is the party
identification of anyone
because the categories have gotten so
scrambled what I care about is whether
you believe in democracy due process the
rights of the individual against the
group or whether you support the kind of
fascism that we're watching right now
which is people breaking in other
people's lawyer's office to gather
information on the Access Hollywood tape
in stormy days look I think it's fair to
I you are simplifying why they broke in
there I do not believe that that was the
only and for only reason why they did it
I don't think that they would have
broken into his office for that I think
there were other criminal enterprises
going on with Michael Cohen that the
investigate that not just this like well
so what are you talking about although
how do you know this do you have some
source in the investigation you know I'm
a lawyer and I understand
attorney-client privilege and I
understand what it would take for a
prosecutor to get a warrant like that it
is not something that they would have
taken lightly especially if it's the
President of the United States that
those should you have totally faith like
all liberals right now you have total
faith in the authorities and if they say
something it must be true and how dare
you as congressman I'm said earlier
today how dare you question you're gonna
go to hell for when did liberals get to
authority I am not loyal to Authority a
pretty good imitation of it but but
Tucker but Tucker you know how could we
assume that it's nefarious and political
I mean I think that the president is
protesting too much of the president
personally okay the New York Times if
you're innocent why do you need a quick
turning client privilege in the first
place why do you need to try sound like
every conservative including you who
I've ever debated over the last eight
never things right as someone who's been
falsely accused of a crime I have not
one time in my life said if you're
innocent why do you need the rights
afforded you by the Bill of Rights I
don't think that I only civil
libertarian I always have been one you
need them because that confuse you all
yeah well I look like a few so many
conservatives I've debated over the
years but look that's the way I've heard
it okay last eight years I've heard
conservative after conservatives say to
me if you're innocent what are you
worried about so the president should
take that advice that's an entire
mindless thing to say and if I've ever
said that I apologize to my hope you did
America Chris thank you it's nice to see
you